do random challenge playing JT be like
once before if you want to play me send
me a challenge but having or like
sending all caps in the chat won't I
won't really help in any way let's play
what to play I don't know what to play
it let's play d5
hey it's Brigham Brigham Aldrich welcome
back
okay I'm gonna play my kind of go to d3
play this I'm insisting on the Stafford
gambit just take my pawn d3 is a sign
that white will not take the pawn though
hey I took the pond okay so it's we've
transposed into a Stafford gambit each
three so each three it's an attempt to
be super safe ironically it leads to uh
if I'm remembering correctly it leads to
a fun position King F 294 remember I
prepared this a while ago it's a funny
line there's a variation in King III and
then castling with this line what's your
favorite TV show it's a good question I
don't really watch TV I have a TV but
I've really never use it I did watch
Breaking Bad at some point also what do
I do here let's play Queen d6
you know I'm forgetting my my
preparation I think it's Queen d6 and
the night by g3 oh I have a good answer
Nathan for you yeah Nathan for you and
breaking bad our or kind of polar
opposites I found out about Nathan for
you after someone compared me to him
like a youtube comment it was a good
show it ended a little bit too soon but
anyway I'm hoping for this move hoping
that White's protects a rook
Queenie ones probably a better a better
approach hopefully Bishop e6
so if rook h2 then it's just meaning now
work h2 is probably possible I'm down a
piece but I have a little bit of calm
compensation
ninety-fourth could be okay so I think
it's time to to cash in and then Castle
so I'm like objectively I'm probably
slightly worse but at least it's a fight
it's imbalanced I have a rook and pawn
for nine Bishop which usually favors the
side with nine bishop
debating which work to move
not sure
another idea it seems like a slow move
but the prospect of playing g5 g4
actually looks really really attractive
well-well focusing too much on the
kingside always play King be it this is
very sneaky
whoa and there's sowing landmines I play
if I play this and there's a see three
wins material
to play like Queenie seven the Queenie
seven still loses material to this
followed by this can't play Queen
squinty five well it's actually playing
well we cannot blundering anything
creating threats
hey it's Gauri thanks for the bits curry
Gauri I was listening to your stream
while driving and then you mentioned me
so now I had I couldn't really type I
was able to at least send an emote Gauri
streamed choker earlier I want to play
f5 it doesn't work also my rook like if
I move to any of these squares I get
Forks so I have to move to this square
but I still get forwards so
wait this is just bad Gauri
do I blame it all on Gauri I probably do
this is my time okay let's play rock out
fades try and cut my losses also
shout-out to Gauri hope you're doing
well
wait okay let's focus in this move okay
so I'm gonna go
basically revert back to losing a piece
yeah shout out to Gauri and then we're
gonna we're gonna focus hardcore 14
seconds down a minute and down a night I
have hope oh that was that's probably a
bad move this would have been a bad
pre-move hopefully opponent doesn't
punish me yeah why could have taken my
bishop because there is a pin and now
I'm just trying to attack some bad
decisions but maybe some good decisions
wait my time I'm in big trouble here I'm
in big trouble
don't Mimi don't find me either oh well
they're dirty finish
there's a miracle I was I was able to
pre move all those moves like two queens
controlling so many squares I don't feel
good about that or do i I don't know
probably not I was really hoping for I
was so disappointed that opponent didn't
allow me I don't know how wonderful that
was but good job j-bird congratulations
keep it up don't stop there
oh did I play jaybird J maybe the J
stands for j-bird or the Beast health
record Kingston with the failfish yeah I
don't know to make of that and this
whole opening is dubious but this line
this is a line like I've looked at in
the past 94 also possible so I could
force a draw but I tried to play on for
more yeah what actually played well here
really just came down to time